[Música]
un llamado al diálogo bipartidista Ese
fue el principal mensaje del presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden al congreso
durante su segundo discurso del estado
de La Unión El mandatario aprovechó su
intervención para Resaltar sus logros en
materia económica el aumento del techo
de la deuda y recuperar los derechos
perdidos tras la revocación de Robert
versus way también estuvieron sobre la
mesa
continúa en Nicaragua la persecución
contra la Iglesia Católica la justicia
nicaragüense condenó recientemente a
siete religiosos a 10 años de prisión
bajo cargos de traición a la patria
Tenemos reporte de nuestro corresponsal
en Centroamérica
al menos 40 personas han muerto hasta el
momento en Perú a causa de los
deslizamientos de tierra provocados por
las intensas lluvias la presidenta Dina
boluarte decretó el estado de emergencia
en uno de los distritos más afectados en
el departamento de Arequipa
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Estados Unidos
con una intervención enfocada en el
diálogo bipartidista el presidente Joe
biden entregó ante el congreso su
segundo discurso del estado de la unión
durante sus declaraciones el mandatario
destacó los logros de sus dos primeros
años de gobierno entre ellos los
económicos como haber rebajado la tasa
de inflación y los índices de desempleo
en el país Asimismo convocó ambos
partidos para trabajar en iniciativas
como vetar las armas de asalto llevar a
cabo una reforma policial y una reforma
migratoria uno de los puntos importantes
fue el pedido que va y deniso al
congreso para aprobar el aumento del
techo de la deuda un tema controversial
que divide a demócratas y republicanos
de esta deuda que nos tomamos 200 años
en acumular solamente tomó la presencia
de una administración y estos son los
hechos mirenlos miren los revisenlos
como respondió el congreso a eso a esa
deuda hicieron lo correcto levantaron el
techo de la deuda tres veces para evitar
la crisis ellos pagaron la cuenta de los
Estados Unidos para impedir un desastre
económico en el país Así que hoy le
estoy pidiendo al congreso que siga esta
esta idea complementamos
para que Estados Unidos y su congreso y
Su autoridad no sea cuestionada otro de
los puntos destacados del discurso fue
el momento en el que Joe biden pidió
trabajar por restaurar la protección al
derecho al aborto que garantizaba la
sentencia conocida como Robert versus
White esto dijo el presidente de Estados
Unidos
El Congreso debe restaurar el derecho
que fue arrebatado en Rose versus
[Aplausos]
tenemos que hacerlo la vicepresidente y
yo estamos haciendo todo lo posible
que haya acceso a la salud reproductiva
y salvaguardas
al menos dos estados están actuando con
leyes restrictivas en abortos si el
congreso aprueba un acta nacional
restrictiva Yo la voy a vetar en el
aspecto internacional Joe biden reiteró
su apoyo férreo a kiev en la Guerra de
Ucrania que está por entrar en sus
primer año por el tiempo que sea
necesario ante la agresión del kremlin
vayan apuntó también a que Estados
Unidos tendrá un papel garante del orden
internacional frente a las amenazas y
ambiciones imperialistas de Putin y
calificó la invasión rusa a Ucrania como
una prueba para el mundo
juntos
Hicimos lo que Estados Unidos siempre
hace su mejor momento liderar unimos a
la otan
creamos una coalición global defendimos
si nos mantuvimos firmes ante la
agresión de Putin
respaldamos a Ucrania y aquí está el
embasador de Ucrania que no solamente
representa a su nación sino al coraje de
su pueblo embajador los trabajadores
saca también
Estados Unidos Aquí en el respaldo de su
país todos tenemos que mirarlo usted
y darle las gracias
[Aplausos]
el mundo está de su lado
por el tiempo que sea necesario
cambiamos de tema vamos a Nicaragua la
persecución contra la Iglesia Católica
continúa la justicia nicaragüense
condenó recientemente a un grupo de
siete religiosos a diez años de cárcel
los integrantes de la Iglesia Católica
son acusados por cargos relacionados con
traición a la patria previamente
hablamos con nuestro corresponsal para
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
quien nos habló sobre los motivos que
tuvo la justicia para condenar a los
religiosos estos siete religiosos
condenados a diez años de prisión eran
los acompañantes de monseñor Rolando
Álvarez El prelado de mayor alto rango
de la Iglesia Católica de Nicaragua en
haber sido arrestado durante el régimen
de Ortega y Murillo un episodio que
ocurrió el pasado 19 de agosto de 2022
el mismo día en que Fue capturado el
obispo Álvarez fueron también arrestados
estos siete religiosos cuatro sacerdotes
dos seminaristas un laico que es un
reportero gráfico de la diócesis de
matagalpa y ellos corrieron otra suerte
del obispo porque fueron llevados
directamente
cárcel el chipote donde están confinados
la mayoría de los opositores del
gobierno de Ortega mientras que al
obispo Álvarez le fue conferido el
beneficio de arresto domiciliario el
pasado 26 de enero la justicia
sandinista resolvió entonces declarar
los culpables por el delito de traición
a la patria que se entiende por haber
menoscabado la integridad del estado y
también por haber difundido noticias
falsas a través de las redes sociales lo
que ahora Les costó una condena de 10
años de cárcel el centro nicaragüense de
los Derechos Humanos calificó esta
decisión de arbitraria y también de una
aberración jurídica Mientras que el
Vaticano y la Iglesia Católica
internacional aún no se ha pronunciado
y aumentó el número de muertos por los
deslizamientos de tierra en el sur de
Perú la defensa civil habla de por lo
menos 40 fallecidos la temporada de
lluvias provocó el desbordamiento de
varios Ríos El domingo el distrito más
afectado fue Mariano Nicolás balcárcel
que fue declarado en estado de
emergencia y allí los daños se
concentraron en el pueblo de secocha y
mixqui primero zonas donde prima la
minería informal la presidenta Dina
boluarte hizo un sobrevuelo Este martes
en la zona afectada y el Ministerio de
defensa envió 4,5 toneladas de ayuda
humanitaria además el centro de
operaciones de emergencia nacional
declaró la alerta Roja en 30 provincias
del país ubicadas en la sierra y en la
selva por las lluvias pronosticadas para
las próximas 24 horas
está llegando a la ayuda humanitaria
pero hoy quisimos sobrevolar la zona
para ver la magnitud del daño ocasionado
sobre todo en la zona donde están
instaladas estas mineras es que las
lluvias también azotan a Bolivia donde
los deslaves han provocado la muerte de
al menos dos personas y 30.000 hectáreas
de cultivo quedaron bajo el agua por
estos seis municipios del departamento
de Santa Cruz fueron declarados en
emergencia y más de 5.500 personas
evacuaron sus casas por las inundaciones
según el más reciente reporte del
viceministro de defensa civil Juan
Carlos calvimonte
las elecciones seccionales y el
referendo que se votó en Ecuador el
domingo le dejaron al presidente
Guillermo lasso un panorama político
bastante adverso el correísmo ganó las
prefecturas en siete de las 24
provincias con lo que revive el
movimiento revolucionario Ciudadana de
revolución ciudadana del expresidente y
ahora opositor Rafael Correa ante este
escenario político la oposición Pide al
presidente adelantar las elecciones al
considerar que ya no tiene la capacidad
política para gobernar además banco el
banco JP Morgan tildó que el panorama
para lasso es muy desafiante después de
las elecciones y que así su margen de
maniobra será limitado hablamos
previamente con Carolina Andrade Quevedo
analista política quien nos explicó Cómo
afecta todo esto a la economía
ecuatoriana
Bueno creo que panoramas bastante
complicado porque Incluso se ha
levantado nuevamente esta la idea esta
propuesta de activar un mecanismo
constitucional que prevé está previsto
en la Constitución ecuatoriana que se
denomina la muerte Cruzada es decir que
la asamblea pueda destituir al
presidente y el presidente también tenga
que y también la asamblea es disuelta Es
decir hay una muerte Cruzada entre el
ejecutivo ya legislativo para
reorganizar elecciones en los próximos
seis meses al inicio de eso era una
propuesta enfocada en una sola
organización política pero durante las
últimas horas esto se ha ampliado a
diferentes actores incluso actores muy
cercanos al oficialismo al gobierno
quienes en un análisis mucho más frío
del que ha sido el que ha realizado el
gobierno a nivel público eh muestran que
el capital político está bastante
desgastado y que esto podría generar
problemas en cuanto a las decisiones a
nivel económico social Las reformas
laborales del sistema de seguridad
social que estaban planteados en la
agenda legislativa Durante este año y
claramente
eso va a tener un efecto en cuanto a la
seguridad jurídica del país también en
cuanto a tener un panorama claro para
los inversores dentro del Ecuador y a
eso se suma la crisis de seguridad que
también ha generado un impacto tanto en
la inversión privada como también en el
tema turístico